[Music]
>> Hi, I'm Dan Fay.
I'm actually here at the Project
Catapult booth where we're
actually making available FPGAs
in a network configuration for
academic researchers to use.
So we have a partnership with
Intel, and we have these
deployed down at UT Austin at
the TACC advanced computing
center and we invite people to
actually test it out and
accelerate their research.
So one of the things we have is
the FPGAs, which you can burn
down to them.
They run at the line of hardware
speed, but they run really fast,
take not too much power.
And we have these deployed down
there, connected with these what
are called our Taurus
connectors.
So they're all directly
connected point to point from
each of these cards, but it
allows you to actually have fast
speed that doesn't have to go
out to the CPU and execute.
So this is a quick, short,
little demo.
We have a receiver that we have
running on this node.
And this is running down at
TACC.
So one of the things I wanted to
do is actually set this node up
These are both running down at
UT Austin at the TACC center,
this node up as a receiver.
So it will sit on the network,
one of these cables, waiting for
information.
And then I'll set this one up as
the transmitter.
And what you're seeing it's
sending about eight gigs of data
very quickly over this link
being processed by the FPGA.
So we can do it in about seven
seconds really quickly.
So wanted to thank you for
taking a look at the Catapult
and hope please come and join
us.
It's at
aka.ms/catapult-academic.